bonjour drieu godefridi vous êtes
spécialiste des états unis merci de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
comment la nomination du remplaçant de
ruth bader ginsburg peut influencer la
campagne présidentielle je crois qu'elle
aura une influence considérable parce
que si effectivement le processus devait
être initiées par le président américain
comme il en a manifesté l'intention il y
aura probablement un déchaînement de
passions à l'instar de ce qui s'est lui
lors de la précédente désignation de
celui qui est finalement devenu le juge
peu après
cabano donc c'est quelque chose qu'il
des clips serait sans doute pas
l'ensemble de la campagne parce que les
américains ont tout même d'autres
préoccupations que la course ou troc
mais cela prendrait instantanément je
dirais une importance traitement
jusqu'au jour de l'élection parce qu'il
est peu probable que la procédure puisse
d'être que le 2 juin avant à l'etrat
novembre le président américain affirme
qu'il choisira une femme on l'a entendu
donald trump message fort ou pure
stratégie politique
il y a probablement un peu des deux
c'est à dire que lol l'avantagé
préserver l'écart des républicains c'est
qu'ils ont publié une liste de juge a
donc potentiel donc de potentiels
candidats à la cour suprême est pas
remis à ses juges il y à une femme qui
se distinguent mais pas seulement par
son sexe aussi par le fait qu'elle est
une des juristes les plus brillants de
sa génération et jelen juge pareil tu es
donc il y a effectivement une
probabilité grande raisonnable aucune
certitude évidemment à ce stade on ne
suis pas informé du choix final du
président que les juges par aep ce soit
la candidate a dû présent d'aquin l'un
des avantages de ce choix c'est que les
démocrates ne pourrait pas la soumettre
au type 2
de critiques haineuses sur le bassin un
peu dissolue je n'irai du juge karen ou
lorsqu'il était lorsqu'il était encore
étudiant ici on a affaire une femme un
juriste d'éminentes mère de sept enfants
dont deux enfants à 2 peu et donc je ne
pense pas que les démocrates qui
seraient pris en porte à faux pourrait
adopter le même type de stratégie sans
doute devrait-il en revenir à critiquer
ses convictions parce que la juge la
règle en question est une catholique
convaincu voir fervente ce qui pour les
démocrates aujourd'hui est devenu tout
simplement inacceptable et ceux qui en
plus ont évidemment sur la dérive
extrémiste du parti démocrate à ton
appel à daniel 30
donc a intérêt forcément à nommer
quelqu'un de républicains est ce qu'il
pourrait choisir une personnalité proche
de ses idées ou quelqu'un de plus
modérée pour gagner une partie de
l'opinion de droite qui ne lui serait
pas favorable
votre question est très intéressante
parce que on assiste depuis 1945
quasiment à un ciel qui consiste pour
les winograd à choisir des personnalités
qui sont souvent de bougeoirs extrême
bouge et pour les bras républicains à
prendre des personnalités modérées qui
parfois se révèle même franchement
démocrate après qu'elle ait été désigné
alors avec trump évidemment tout cela a
changé
le parti républicain c'est maintenant
réorganiser dans son intégralité
autour de l'esprit je dirais qu'on
d'actifs du président américain
et donc il est peu probable que son
choix se porte sur une personnalité qui
ne soit pas clairement à engager sur ce
que l'on appelle le respect de la
constitution c'est-à-dire interpréter le
texte de la constitution tel qu'il a été
rédigé et non pas vouloir le réinventer
au gré des modes ce qui est plutôt
effectivement la vision progressiste
comme comme on dit c'est à dire celles
des démocrates donc il est très peu
probable à ce stade que le choix du
président américain se porte sur un
candidat qui débat qui ne qui ne
quittent ac n'est pas comme ça tire sans
américain assez fort assez convaincu on
sait que la cour suprême est un temps
plein du droit aux états unis
donald trump et est un conservateur ses
plus proches partisans sont contre
l'avortement
pour certains démocrates une nomination
faite par donald trump et pourrait être
synonyme de recul sur les droits de
l'homme est ce que ce sont des craintes
fondées
elle veut tout votre question et dont il
va très très intelligente mais son son
formule est assez typique une question
il n'y aura évidemment aucun recul des
droits de l'homme faire que ce que les
républicains haskell comme ça at il
défendu
ce sont les droits de l'homme tels
qu'ils sont inscrits dans la
constitution décennies mais ceci vous
avez parfaitement raison c'est que l'un
des grands enjeux aujourd'hui à devant
les consultants c'est le sort et
l'avenir de la version web qui en 1973 a
légalisé l'avortement au nom du droit à
la vie privée c'est-à-dire virtuellement
l'appartement sans limite midi
conditions dit et c'est quelque chose
qu'un grand nombre de coups de savate et
de républicains n'ont jamais accepté
il est garde en nommant des juges comme
un père et nous et comme peut-être
maintenant la juge d'arrêt on essaye du
côté républicain du caté comme ça at il
de faire pencher la balance je dirais
dans l'autre direction
et de revenir sur cette légalisation
intégrale de l'appartement mais les
républicains allaient comme ça at il
considère que cette légalisation n'a
jamais été un progrès est donc pour eux
ce serait évidemment en provenance
remettre un certain nombre de limites
sur ce que l'on appelle le droit
effectivement à l'appartement donc tout
ça n'est qu'une question de moyens mais
poser le débat simplement en termes de
revenus des droits de l'homme c'est déjà
prendre position sur le fond
dernière question très rapidement drieu
godefridi en a plus beaucoup de temps
mais on sait qu'en ce moment il ya le
mouvement black light madoff aux
etats-unis est-ce que donald trump
pourrait proposer un noir a mis tout
savoir que déjà à aller cour suprême et
stacy et depuis le décès de l'admirable
juge scalia le juge le plus républicain
le juge le plus comme ça attire le juge
le plus à droite et le juge clarence
thomas autres juristes éminents et qui
est aussi noir qu'on peut l'être
donc oui il est très possible que le
président un gain a nommé
servi d'américains droit aux plus hautes
fonctions y compris dans l'armée autour
de lui cette idée d'un racisme des
républicains était évidemment voir une
patate chaude
ici je pense que le plus probable sera
effectivement la désignation d'un
candidat sur la foi de ses qualités de
juriste mais également sur son sexe et
donc je pense que le choix devrait se
porter sur une femme noire de l'union
merci drieu godefridi d'avoir répondu à
une question je rappelle que vous êtes
docteur en philosophie et auteur de
reload comment l'amérique se vante le
siècle aux éditions de l'exquis